how many people here have used chat GPT
or an AI think I don't think people
realize that Alexa and Google home and
apple home are about to use this for
real for real I don't think people
realize it's going to look like this hey
Alexa I have six of my son's friends
coming over two are lactose intolerant
one is vegan three are a mess and I'd
like them to eat and I'd like them to
eat a little
healthier I only have a couple hundred
bucks in budget and they'll be here for
about four or 5 hours but I'll also need
something quick and snacky in the
morning cuz they're going to sleep over
and I want to send them home with
something send it that's how people are
going to shop so what I just said is
real life in 57 nine 10 years